it's time for our very special pop quiz
it's pop quiz week and we're going big
we've got this fabulous money booth here
for one special audience member to step
in and grab all the cash they can
there's also two special tickets that we
put in there because if they grab one
or both a gold ticket they win a grand
prize and if they grab the silver one
then everyone in the audience goes yeah
just a little something
just a little something all right so
you're ready to play
where is amy zaslansky
get yourself down here
[Applause]
hi amy hi amy hi drew hi ross how are
you
super excited a little nervous but
excited oh don't be nervous deep breath
we'll just lamaze through it okay just
i noticed that you're carrying some
books
i do
so i wanted to just tell you a little
bit about the charity the book fairies
and what we do is we collect books for
kids in need all across long island and
the five boroughs we take
all the books that are sitting unused on
people's bookshelves that people don't
need anymore and we give them to the
kids to make sure that they're able to
read and succeed
i did my research and i know that one of
drew's favorite books
is dr seuss all the places you go
so i wanted to give drew a gift but i
couldn't leave ross
so this is one of my favorites is the
lorax and
the coolest thing is
it's actually by bookjournals.com
it's a journal
come on
thank you so much
thank you
thank you so much guess what
oh you're getting on the shelf
[Applause]
thank you amy i will chronicle all the
places i can now finally go again oh
amazing amazing well you're not supposed
to be giving us gifts this is about you
grabbing that money
oh amy i'm so excited okay we're gonna
ask you three questions about the show
every question you answer right that's
an extra 10 seconds in the booth okay
you can remove your mask you can remove
your mask because we're far away and you
can put on those goggles and that apron
to get ready okay max we don't want
shirts of cash going in your pupils very
dangerous
um okay our first question is who is kim
kardashian holding hands with on a
roller coaster over the weekend
snl's pete davidson joined them and was
spotted on a roller coaster holding
counts with kim k and they say
reportedly they're just friends oh
they're just
friends i know this one that is pete
davidson
that's 10 seconds okay that's 10 seconds
proud of you amy okay second question
what did drew and an audience member amy
have in common does anyone else like
have kids at a messy car
thank you to the one woman
and they have in common with me we all
have messy minivans because we all have
kids and life is messy
yes yes yes
all right you got two questions right
there's 20 seconds here's your final
question all right i'm ready what is the
name of kristen bell and dak shepard's
family focused company how and why did
you take on this enterprise in the next
phase of your beautiful company hello
bellow hello bella
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we go i'm going to put
the gold bill and the silver bill in
there
all right
angel are we ready
okay get ready set yeah
oh
[Applause]
okay
i'm like you were definitely the most
casual which i liked it didn't feel
casual it felt a little frantic yeah
well let me just tell you you're calm in
a storm that's good literally this was
you you were like
that one that one's cute
i like i like your style and approach
all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break and count how much amy
grabbed a money bank
[Music]
no i think you're sexy and unfrantic
congratulations thank you um welcome
back before the break amy had 30 seconds
to collect as much money as she could
in our money birth and she looks super
money while grabbing money
um so it turns out that uh the gold or
silver ticket did not get grabbed i know
but you did get some cash um are you
ready to find out how much you won yes
you won
492 dollars
thank you for our gifts and thank you
for everything that you do by
distributing books to children thank you
for doing that thank you for ours too
keep up the great work
[Music]
you